we had to youthful discussion with the
social partners on the role in stepping
Cup employment and growth in Europe the
recovery is underway but Europe
continues to pay the social costs of the
crisis the political damage I have in
mind the rise of population for example
is also growing our exchange highlighted
that we need to work on the social
dimension of the economic and monetary
union the five presidents report has
given us ideas on how to do this the
social summit also discussed the refugee
crisis including the challenge of
receiving and integrating refugees
coming to Europe with no prospect of
being able to return home in the
medium-term the social partners have a
huge role to play here and finally we
also discover the possible impact the
migration influx may have on the
European labor market and our economy we
don't want to be constantly facing
shocks and crises such as the crises
we've experienced of late we need to
make sure that were properly prepared
that the economic and monetary union is
not lacking and can deal with such
crises so what we now have to do is work
on the five presidents report build on
that and today again the European
Council will be addressing this point in
that context the deepening of the
economic and monetary union the social
dimension has to be not only taken
seriously but truly incorporated into
the economic governance of the economic
and monetary union we really need not
only to help save and welcome refugees
for humanitarian reasons but also
because they can be really are a source
in an added value for Europe Europe
needs migrants and refugees to have a
better label market a more skilled labor
market better economy growth and also
social cohesion and better culture and
multiculturalism in its own society